along the banks of the phalemia river in
southern mali children search for gold
some are here with their parents others
are alone orphans from the war in the
sahel region they come from all over
west africa to the many illegal mines
here
she's 15 but appears to be barely 12. in
this gold rush adults hope to get rich
while the children hope to find just
enough to buy a meal
i am the eldest in the family and so i'm
in charge of supporting my sisters and
brother and helping my mother find food
in the morning i do the chores then i
come to work to search for gold if we
find something i buy the food then i
make the meal school is not an option
for me or any of the children here
after toiling for 16 hours a day finding
gold is a welcome prospect for the men
but for the children there's fear
men seeking sex offer money to desperate
girls as young as 12 who are left with
little choice either accept the abuse or
go hungry
the u.n says 1.6 million children
worldwide are forced into selling sex to
survive
you see those children working those two
girls behind me they're with their mom
they can make up to 36 dollars in a day
with that money they can help their
entire family this system of work is
essential
the economic fallout of the pandemic and
the rising costs of living means poverty
for millions of families the un says
almost 10 million children globally will
stop school and start working before the
end of the year jukunda's mother says
adults depend on their children to work
if i had the means of course my daughter
would not be working here of course
school is better in the long run she's
not working by choice her dad is old
there are seven other relatives and we
all depend on her
jukunda didn't find gold but she did
find a way to make money how she earned
it she isn't saying but it's enough to
buy a meal for her family
the burden of care is given to the young
robbed of their childhood and forced to
earn a living like adults
nicholas hawk al jazeera